within weeks of 9/11 the Patriot Act was
passed in the US with no congressional
debate it allowed unprecedented
surveillance with minimal oversight over
American citizens the alternative the
government suggested was responsibility
for another terrorist attack the laundry
list of things that the intelligence
community had wanted for many years at
the time their assurances the measures
would be temporary but they've been
routinely reauthorized by Congress yet
mass surveillance proved ineffective
counterproductive and the data was being
used for purposes unrelated to terrorism
it was only 12 years after the Patriot
Act passed with the whistleblowing of
Edward Snowden that we discovered the
extent of the mass surveillance and only
then was the government's bulk
collection of information about
Americans limited now with the spread of
covert 19 Snowden and others say there's
an opportunity to learn from the past a
systems to monitor everyone's location
at all times are being formalized in
secret at the point these policies are
being sought these benefits are
theoretical often there is no evidence
for them and they may never materialize
that capability will exist in three
months in three years and in 30 years if
we allow it to be implemented today
clusters of disease do need to be
located swiftly and closed-off and
smartphone data is being used to locate
those not adhering to social distancing
requirements but we have a few specific
details on data collection Facebook and
Google have been in talks with the
government on sharing information they
collect about us online advertising
companies that track our movements are
discussing new covert 19 revenue streams
the firm Palantir whose data collection
has been key to the Trump
administration's deportation program is
creating covert 19 models for the
government I think common washings a
good term for essentially companies and
I see context pointless opportunity to
under their application and to set
themselves up to normalize their
techniques and to eventually profit from
what's been called for is full
transparency exactly what information is
being collected by whom how long has it
been kept for and how is it being used
particularly by law enforcement agency
it is traditionally the disadvantage in
society who bear the weight of
surveillance right you know we talk
about the color of surveillance well the
color of surveillance is black and brown
and that's definitely something to be
thinking about when you think about data
when you think about health data when
you think about the ways in which health
data could be misused in a variety of
particularly commercial contexts for to
treat people differently when they
shouldn't be the consequences of
pandemic policy for civil liberties go
beyond electronic surveillance and
president shows a robust debate needs to
occur before policies are enacted and
not after she a burton c al jazeera
washington